[Music]
[Applause]
this week we have a Christmas petition
clause for alarm the wrath of Krampus is
kind of sad right yes so Fabi sad letter
to Santa take it away Tiffany for our
first story there is the cell phone
video that captured a woman screaming at
a mall Santa saying that he's not real
what an adult woman oh I know she
finally realized he's not real and it
crushed her dreams I feel like that's
what happened she got pissed I feel like
I can relate as an adult yes as an adult
I had dreams I didn't believe in Santa
Claus ever God what kind of kid real
well I didn't know about Santa Claus
really like I just knew of him as this
you know TV person mime Perry was a TV
personality so like when we were you
know in elementary school I got in
trouble because these kids like Oh
Santa's coming I don't let you [ __ ] it's
stupid like that man doesn't exist you
know cuz it wasn't taught to me so I got
it you never saw Christmas movies I did
but that's it was a movie it wasn't real
so it didn't register like that but I
knew Santa didn't exist when I asked for
Michelangelo and I got Donatello and no
one likes Donatello and I got it in my
fireplace yeah I was like who would do
something like this my mom you know I
like all that can I get those Nikes sure
thing let's go to Payless jaws are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't want Donatello
sucked it was because his weapon was
just a piece of wood yeah [ __ ] whack
now that I have a sudden I don't know if
I want to teach him about Santa Claus
like I just teach him well teach you
about Santa Claus but I'm gonna be like
yo that white man didn't buy you [ __ ] I
bought it for you ladies the brown baby
Lord our lady got you a lot of things
the independent colored water
sonica color color people like say Negro
thanks hang more like fake Negro such as
old arcade term colored woman the cheeks
I'm a color woman
I was saying what if you just buy the
gift from Santa as a cheap-ass one and
you buy them all the bottom ones
Oh reverse psychology for me
what were the Santa ones like a [ __ ]
sock no I don't really pick any really
he no like I wouldn't really say like oh
this is the the present you really want
some sales from me like I don't really
do does he still believe in Saturday no
because he made it such a big occasion
where at the stroke of midnight on the
24th he would spend he would hire
someone to go up to the roof and make
make all the noise it was such a
fantastic Wow
what if it was just a robber every year
someone hired my uncle and night that's
when I started it maybe Santa wasn't
real because like my house that's when
he let go of the dog you're like that is
so cool he went through he just was that
kind of guy and so I wrote letters to
Santa up until last year you guys uh I
guess here I will do it too that's
awesome
where do you send it to I send it to my
mom okay you still write letters to son
I do what do you write to him
yes weird that I like I'm an atheist but
like I picture God my Christmas God I
all year for Christmas that's dope oh
you know makes sense the the dog Jack
cake riding the Santa Claus you and
Bobbie Lee ordered a very healthy push
it all makes sense down [ __ ] get your
first tree oh yeah my first tree his mom
is a woman of depravity that's what she
is what she likes
Bobby I we bought his first tree two
years ago too
oh and I had to drag him out the house
for that he said it was the worst human
experience the worst human experience
like why the [ __ ] are we in a parking
lot with trees also did you actually
also how are these trees growing this
parking lot
oh my childhood dreams like shattered in
nomads parking lot [ __ ] is [ __ ] wack
you got to go and [ __ ] saw your own
[ __ ] down have you ever done that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that tree these things are farmed
no like I'm talking about there's a farm
you not steal your tree what Golf Course
yeah
not doing battery did that a couple
times no we've had um so you go to Apple
Hill near North Cal and they have a
whole [ __ ] Christmas tree farm and
then you get to pick your own and then
you can saw it down put it on your truck
and everything how far away is it Ken
can I convince Bobby to do this for use
about seven hours away
oh so for Sacramento it's about an hour
issuance oh but it's it's dumb it's
[ __ ] fun like kids love it too
all right so I'm gonna show you guys the
video of this woman
it's done
oh she's crazy she's got that mr.
Cheever you're not magic conniving real
oh my God look at his body all the kids
there are no kids right there's always
kids waiting well he's big oh he got a
[ __ ] thug walk though that's we'll
definitely no normal Santa yeah she was
saying do you have a play you [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you have a sleigh you're not
magic you're not even real I heard about
it when I was a young kid you're not
real man she's telling the truth though
yeah she's real I mean that's the same
thing your Disneyland you [ __ ] your
Mickey you ain't real I know you're some
[ __ ] ethnic [ __ ] and David
goes I know what do you mean I know
you're some like high school kid what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that was weird
dude that's the rat at Chuck E Cheese
ever talk to you guys he's a rapist
you know that one game where you throw
the ball and it goes up and it shoots us
in the kibo skee-ball really shoot up
that high but I was thinking I was
taking the ball and I was trying to
throw it into the hole like I was
playing baseball
what are you got your ass itches rat
came up to me they go stop [ __ ] doing
that yeah that's a permanent smile after
that oh my god you were a devil dude you
could've told me nicely no way you were
chucking that [ __ ] dude those balls are
heading you're a [ __ ] bag prepare for
you're supposed to be on my site oh yeah
yeah that would a dick [ __ ] house [ __ ]
you mouth my cousin had crazy like rage
problems when he was like in junior high
and then we went to Universal Studios
and do you guys remember Fido the mouse
yeah dog or something mouse
yeah and then they had the whole show
and everything
so Fido came up to him took off his hat
and just [ __ ] hit his head like
really aggressively
and put the hat back on he got up and
[ __ ] roundhouse kicked him and
started punching the [ __ ] out of the
security had to drag him off well she
was like a [ __ ] Tasmanian devil on
him and then all the kids were like my
hero and then he was like he was like
[ __ ] tied up and then the security
was like taking yeah and I was like oh
my god he's my [ __ ] hero that's bad
and then like I was just looking for one
of those animals to [ __ ] up one day I
just wanted to be just like him yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] up a [ __ ] Mouse dude
alright next story have you guys heard
of Krampus Knut
what is that I don't know it is not
Krampus you talking about the German
Santa Claus yeah everyone you're talking
about [ __ ] get on class I'll continue
I'll think of it later and that the
truce and I'm like that's the real
that's the real [ __ ] dude in other
countries like a pagan figure it's
celebrated a lot in central Eastern
Europe so he's Armenian Santa Claus yeah
hey bro Glen what do you want for
christmas yeah this figure he's kind of
like the Christmas devil so he's
supposed to be like the balance of good
and evil so that he's supposed to be
like the partner of the good Santa that
we know his name black Peter no are you
talking about suave Pete my parents used
to scare me the [ __ ] out of Christmas I
was like Harry ball because that dude
was that back in the day it was just a
white dude doing blackface oh yeah no he
wasn't
I don't know but then black Peter is
like he's like a kidnapper and if so
it's like if you're good you get
presents oh maybe the English version
yeah and and black Peter will come and
he'll [ __ ] kidnap your ass and molest
you
there is that's the story no I added
that extra to make him even more evil
yeah so the story is like with Krampus
that oh my bad I jumped the gun no ya
know cuz that shouldn't terrified me
like a [ __ ] he looked like
Gandalf and [ __ ] and my parents used to
say if you're bad black Peters gonna
come and kidnap your ass yeah if you're
good
here's a present why I gotta be black
white satin black Peter no it's a white
Santa he's like he looks like Gandalf
but he's like the Grim Reaper and [ __ ]
he's wearing all black and [ __ ] yeah so
in like Austria for example they have
this whole celebration where they have
people dress up as Kremp rumpus okay you
can't show kids that holy [ __ ]
celebrated on December 5th which is the
day before December 6 which is the day
that they celebrate actual Santa so you
don't need to beat your kids if you just
tell them this that is oh yeah and so he
carries like a bastard kid yeah and they
just go around like scaring kids as part
of the tradition I think I would do that
know if I told my kids that Santa
existed I'm gonna do that as well yep so
when they misbehave I'm gonna be in the
clock see that guy's face every night
there's balance right
yeah that's balance I like that no so
when they're good when they look in the
closet is Santa Claus he has a lot of
[ __ ] gifts or if they're bad that
[ __ ] comes on campus cops or
make it the opposite make dismal the
[ __ ] give him the gifts and the
positive stuff and bring a regular old
fast Santa Claus that eat like make us
on your child scared of fat white guys
it's a terrible idea
Asian parenting just all scared that
scare texture oh that's negative
reinforcement yeah I love it I love it
it produces the best type of people in
the world I love Christmas snowman
Christmas is my [ __ ] yeah I already
decorated my [ __ ] room and everything
I got a Christmas tree in my room not
because the house is the bottom stairs
is too cold so I stay in my rooms
do you wish its northern are they I
would but people can't even drive in the
rain so snow might be a really bad idea
it scary yeah I wish there's black eyes
you want tight though Christmas we turn
off all the light that you leave all the
Christmas lights on it's like this
perfectly lit place
it feels dope on the insides man and you
take the ice cubes in your door another
room floor so it's more festive and then
you turn on the a/c and open the
refrigerator door you guys anything
where you walk around like a Moloch and
Macy's and just take it all in dude I
used as a kid what is take it all in me
I steal you know cause like Maisie makes
during Christmas you know I go like
obviously like just go and get samples
of like perfect perfume my grandma go
shop and like the makeup store but I
like like all the Christmas trees the
presidents and I'll just smell the
makeup I'm Filipino
oh you get the warm fuzzies from that
yeah you're trying to give yourself the
warm fuzzies they do decorate the mall
pretty legit though during chrises yeah
they do
yeah there's a [ __ ] weird story
though woman's purse it's like one of
those stories that you want everybody to
relate to but nobody can remember when
you were a kid and you smell perfume all
the time like the Glendale Galleria is
[ __ ] prettiest [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
every hour like every hour they do this
you know what sucks here though because
there's no seasons in LA like even on
the way here I was listening to [ __ ]
Christmas songs but it's too [ __ ]
sunny
listening to [ __ ] salt yeah it was too
[ __ ] sunny and the fires are raging
yeah there's just it doesn't feel like
Christmas it's not it's not right
it's Satan's Christmas with the - you
know it's dope about downtown in the Le
life they have a ice rink there oh the
line there is [ __ ] horrendous dude we
try to go last year sing squares person
squirrels and there's another one in Le
lab that husband - I'm just impatient
but if you're down to wait in line we
did it before for a dick adventure oh
yeah the one that I didn't go to oh
that's what was fun oh yeah you weren't
there I don't know where I was that you
guys did Bobby ever tell you that he's
like a professional like ice skater
get the [ __ ] out of here what because
you played ice hockey oh yeah
like the Burbank Pickwick and I'm like
skating that he leaves his graceful
doing just like probable axles he
sharpens his own blade he brings his own
- how did it get into these sports like
hot wrestling hardly enough he's the
most agile person ever man what the most
agile you know there's some people who
look the part but can't really like run
or hear or not yeah yeah he doesn't look
the part at all but he is the most
athletic person physically like he can
do tumbles he's gonna [ __ ] triple
axels [ __ ] amazing
he's nothing about who makes sense how
he's alive to be honest with you like
the way he functions I just picture him
with this little belly
you know man just [ __ ] graceful it's
very nice I like looking at his
Instagram very sparingly because I like
to see him constantly transform into
this trashy human being like when I
first saw him like when I first found
out I was like oh man Bobby Lee looks
the same and then three months later
what's going on like it's you getting
progressively more successful but he's
looking more trashy that's his goal his
goal is to look like a homeless Japanese
man in Hawaii it's already their last
story there's this six year old that was
told to write a letter to Santa Claus
that's cool and so his mom tweeted out
his letter so this is mom Sarah she
tweeted my six-year-old Santa skeptic
was told to write a letter to Santa at
school so he did this is what it looked
like that's hella decorate that will
can't write for [ __ ] he thinks I know
but yeah that's the year right my baby's
in parenting kicks in right there from a
girl she looks good you know why I
remember writing like that because I
didn't want to do my work I half-assed
it off I remember that [ __ ] you can't
[ __ ] fool me kid I take my time and
do [ __ ] if I cared about it you can't
fool this kid either when Constanta goes
what he said dear Santa Santa I'm only
doing this for the class I know your
naughty list is empty and your good list
is empty and your life is empty oh you
don't know the trouble I've had in my
life
goodbye love I'm not telling you my name
is that kid of the snowflake feature is
the color of his skin
George is he from the caucus George is
this your letter and then he's drew like
skulls and wreaths that's it dude
I mean very punk rock and I commend the
kid but also like he gets beats for sure
and like it was like thrown in a dungeon
no that's a kid no that's a kid who
doesn't get beep I get to say whatever
the [ __ ] you want I don't think that's
what it is that's some snowflake
behavior that's anger writing you don't
die in the mailbox
it looks like he wrote die cuz you know
what this reminds me of so in the condo
that I'm renting out we have people next
to us that are of the fair-skinned
nature and every morning we get to hear
this kids speak and scream scream mainly
mm-hmm the other day I was we woke up to
this you have to take a shower you have
to listen to mommy mommy is the adult I
am the boss of you my mom's what that
reminds me of cuz what what happened to
my house quick conversation that's what
I wake up to every [ __ ] morning and
that's kind of cute when you hear other
people no it's not I want to take my
fist
Mosca through the [ __ ] wall grab that
little girl's hair and smash it ended up
laying she said would you like to read
mm-hmm which one which was nervous okay
the moms were fine Oh PS the troubles in
his life question mark
his brother film called child services
ha ha ha ha and then the second one was
the last few days have been insane only
one other thing I want to say about my
little skeptic he's not a skeptic he's
an [ __ ]
he is a wonderful bright sweet
passionate boy who loves his brother and
his dog and loves the holidays
he just likes adults to level with him
I'll get that he wants adults to level
with him that's what I'm saying he's one
of those kids why does he even get that
respect I'll get that I like the fact
that the kids intelligent this which is
kind of cool but there's that
double-edged sword because he's that
little kid that tries to talk to an
adult like he knows more than them I
think that's why they had to be taught
he's gonna grow up to be a sanctimonious
little [ __ ] I already know the end game
of that and it's a girl I went to
nursing school with and that's she is
the adult version of what that kid was a
little kid I guarantee you that little
kids favorite word is actually and
that's why you grab the [ __ ] faces
smash it against the wall a couple of
times and then you hug them as always I
love you God loves you yeah yeah it's
like um it's like I do it because I love
you yeah yeah I've got that one yeah I
beat your ass because I love you yeah
and then I was like well I love you a
lot
come here yes but then I got my ass beat
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]